but you've also done is it a punching
game this is her game she did this game
what my drink
she taught is this game I didn't I
brought it you did bring we used to do
it in The Hunger Games in like a normal
way because you're poor you know you
spend minimum 12 hours unset so it's
like you know you see the circle you get
punched and on Hunger Games that's
normal I brought it to these psychos and
now it's it's truly truly dangerous
did you look normal
it's terrifying it's like vagina
[Applause]
taxes to italic something's going to
happen with a beard how do I get
unloaded on single guy a swingers close
your drink sorry I just fingered your
gin and tonic
you've got no idea what darkness is just
about yourself into this is the film
we're finally at your version of
Professor X becomes bald Peter do you
yes did you shave your head originally
all the years back ago net but a wig on
you or something I I shaved it months
before when I came to the job just to
see if it was look like and just - can I
see and then I turned up with about two
months clothes thinking would shave
again and so they they spend a 17-hour
my first of two seventeen our head
extension sessions getting the head
extension spoon Wow yeah so I've all the
x-men movies I've either had hair
extensions or a wig but this time proper
proper proper follicly challenged yeah
that's me stop it it looks good
what's the thing with Patrick Stewart
but he was somehow involved in the
shaving he's been involved since the
very beginning yeah when I went to shave
my head I was shaving it and we thought
hey what would at it why don't we try
and FaceTime Patrick and as we were
shaving it he said please back it up and
send me some hair and I could use it ha
ha ha ha that's funny and then we just
walked away and if the hair was on the
floor and all that stuff turns out that
the director did back up and he he has
all my hair at home and a safe which is
kind of creepy
witchcraft well I think I don't know
about yourselves that a lot
a salt and pepper mill lovely
[Music]
you